is this one of the world's most
dangerous millennials
muhammad bin salman crown prince of
saudi arabia
better known as mbs
to some he's a revolutionary who has
transformed life in saudi arabia
especially for women
to others he's a butcher
who fueled a bloody war in yemen
and the cia believes approved an
operation to kill or capture a
washington post journalist
who was cut up with a bone soul
now thanks to the global energy crisis
the crown prince looks stronger than
ever
and world leaders are queuing up to get
their hands on his oil i think the
kingdom is in a uniquely
uh powerful position with what is
happening in ukraine
so what will he do next
mbs is a very dangerous man who is
becoming more dangerous because of the
power he's accumulating
after hours in saudi arabia
men and women mixing freely and a female
dj on the decks
the economists nicholas pelham was
filming the scene i think i had to do a
double take it was really quite an
astonishing sight
just a few years ago all this would have
been illegal
public entertainment was banned and
unmarried men and women were not allowed
to socialize saudi arabia for all the
time that i've known it until about the
last five or six years has been a
society where public sport space was
ruled by religious police what i found
so hard to grapple with was just how
normal it all felt i don't understand
how you can live with one set of values
and then to plant them with another as
if nothing had really happened
in the past saudi arabia was governed
according to a strict interpretation of
islam
clerics controlled everything from
social life to the role of women
the kingdom uh really was ruled through
a joint venture if you want between the
royal family and the hard-line religious
establishment and it was an
ultra-conservative establishment you
know controlled education controlled the
public narrative
that was until the rise of muhammad bin
salman
the young crown prince stripped the
clerics of their power
increased women's rights including
giving them the right to drive
and all in a radically short period of
time
if you look at it in a historical
context
of what societies had to go through to
neuter
their conservative right-wing religious
class that usually only happened with
civil wars this has all happened without
a single cleric being you know killed or
no violence on the streets and i think
that is virtually miraculous really
[Music]
so who is the man behind these changes
mbs is a millennial who enjoys flaunting
his wealth
he splashed out over 200 million pounds
on a french chateau
the economist was given a rare chance to
sit down with him in 2016
and found a prince ready for power there
wasn't a single question that he shied
away from um his responses were
imaginative and detailed and he was
forthcoming and i think what came across
perhaps most stridently was a sense of
conviction he really believed in his
ability to change the kingdom
despite his confidence few could have
predicted mbs's rise
in saudi arabia's ruling dynasty the
house of saud power usually passes
sideways
from brother to brother
mbs's father salman had several older
brothers ahead of him in line for
succession
but when two died he was able to take
the throne
opening up the way for mbs to succeed
him
although he still had several older
half-brothers ahead of him in line for
the throne
it wasn't clear that the line of
succession was going to pass from one
generation to the next and if you were
going to move to the next generation
there were many princes who were far
better known mahogan salman was
an unknown quantity
but his father salman had a soft spot
for him
so when he became king in 2015 he
increased mbs's portfolio
these are just some of the titles he was
given
then in 2017 according to insider
reports
mbs forced his cousin to step aside as
crown prince
there was seems to have been something
of a standoff muhammad bin knife and his
guards were disarmed mohammed bin laden
was told that your time is up the
council of allegiance has decided that
you are no longer the crown prince and
i'm going to fill your shoes
after this mbs wasted no time in
cementing his power
it's a shakeup sending shockwaves across
the kingdom and the world saudi arabia
detaining top officials in a sweeping
corruption probe he invited the
wealthiest men in the kingdom along with
the world's business elite to a
conference on the future of the saudi
economy
a self-styled davos in the desert
and a short time later he used the
opportunity to hold many of them in a
luxury hotel
he rounded up
the leading princes and the richest
businessmen interrogated them got them
to reveal their banking details
thereafter it was very clear that the
real only ruler in the kingdom was now
mohammed bin salman
since then his aggression and repressive
behavior have escalated
he has consolidated power around his own
court
human rights groups estimate thousands
have been detained
and in march this year alone 81 were
executed
the government has maintained an
extremely tight control of society and i
think that is a price
the kingdom
has had to pay for social peace as it
transitions
through this wrenching process
some are much more skeptical
khalid al jabri says he knows first hand
how brutal the regime can be
when when all you have is a hammer
everything becomes a or everybody
becomes a nail that's exactly what mbs
is doing and
his list of victims will keep expanding
uh inside and outside saudi arabia
unless somebody decides to put a check
on him
khalid lives in america
but his roots are in saudi arabia
i come from a big family uh in terms of
western standards i'm the eldest
six boys and and two girls including
amaransara they were funny
smart it's very very ambitious
in 2017 omar and sarah were banned from
leaving the kingdom three years later
they were seized by the authorities
there were 20 unmarked civilian cars
that showed up with 50 officers in plain
clothes
that went into the house and basically
took umransara
khalid's father was an adviser to the
former crown prince mohammed bin nayef
thinks his siblings travel ban has been
used by mbs to try to pressure his dad
to return to the kingdom
and he has seen messages from mbs to his
father which he believes support this
what's so unique about our case is
mohammed bin salman can deflect
responsibility on
on rogue asians or that he doesn't know
about it
it's a complicated story
khalid's dad is also accused of stealing
billions of dollars from the saudi
government which he denies
meanwhile khalid worries about his own
security
i think like my father i made
peace with the fact that one day i will
probably be harmed and who can blame him
mbs has famously been linked to the
murder of outspoken former royal court
insider and journalist jamal khashoggi
who was dismembered with a bone soul in
the saudi consulate in istanbul
nicholas knew him personally
we were due to meet actually in istanbul
uh the weekend that he he disappeared i
think hamilton saw man he wanted to send
a message that this is what happens when
you question my authority
[Music]
mbs has said he takes responsibility for
the murder but denies ordering it
for a time it looked like the killing
could jeopardize the kingdom's
relationship with one of its closest
allies
america
we were going to in fact make them pay
the price and make them in fact the
pariah that they are
saudi arabia has long been a strategic
ally in the middle east successive
presidents have happily sold arms to
saudi leaders we really have a great
friendship a great relationship crown
prince thank you very much thank you for
being here
it's also home to the world's largest
accessible oil reserves
and thanks to the energy crisis caused
by the war in ukraine president biden's
threats now look empty
the message from ukraine has been that
the global economy still depends on oil
from the gulf it was also significant
that it wasn't just uh biden who came to
saudi arabia it was also the most
powerful leaders in the arab world it
was almost as if mohammed bin salman was
sending the message i'm your address in
the middle east if you want to have a
relationship with the middle east if you
want to keep
russia and china away from dominating
the region deal with me
so where might change come from
let's start in the kingdom itself
there may be little overt opposition but
some including religious hardliners are
unhappy with his reforms
mohammed bin salman really is ruling by
fear i saw it on my recent visits more
than i've ever seen it before it does
beg the question as it has for other uh
totalitarian leaders in the middle east
how long can you continue to rule by
fear and by force and at what point
could that be a breaking point
another weak point is the economy
since taking power he has dedicated
himself to diversifying the kingdom away
from oil
with everything from tourism to flashy
eco cities like neon
you see ancient lands
we see the world tomorrow
this is neon
but despite the glossy pr promises of
new cities in the sand unemployment is
still in double figures
while many of the oil-related subsidies
saudis have traditionally enjoyed are
gone
he hasn't really had much success in
diversifying revenues the kingdom is
still heavily dependent on oil and looks
as if it will be for the foreseeable
future so what what does that mean if if
if he can't deliver and if you see a
rise in economic frustration there's a
huge question mark as to whether that
could also translate into political
frustration
so what about threats beyond the kingdom
the most immediate is right on his
doorstep in yemen as defence minister
back in 2015 one of the first things mbs
did was intervene in a bloody war to
crush houthi rebels who were being
supported by the kingdom's arch rival
iran but seven years on the houthis have
forced the better-armed saudis into a
ceasefire
which still leaves the kingdom looking
exposed well the kingdom is very
vulnerable houthis have been succeeding
in getting through although saudi air
defense have improved their game
considerably over the past couple of
years but still the kingdom is a very
wide geographic
space
and that makes it particularly
vulnerable to drones
and other um projectiles that come
either from iran or from iran's
proxies
but perhaps the greatest threat to the
crown prince might be mbs himself
he's shown himself to be ego driven
aggressive and impulsive
and perhaps it's only so long before he
makes a fatal misjudgment
is it his own recklessness is it his own
brutality
is it his own uh
desire to be the only voice in the
kingdom that could ultimately prove his
undoing for sound policy you need to
have people who can say no and at the
moment in saudi arabia everyone is too
scared to say anything but yes
we put the allegations in this film to
the royal court in saudi arabia it
declined to comment
but in response to a related piece about
mbs in the economist it denied all
allegations against the crown prince
insisting they are fabricated and
without foundation it continued the
kingdom is unfortunately used to false
accusations made against its leadership
usually based on politically or other
motivated malicious sources
my name is nicholas pelham i'm the
middle east correspondent for the
economist if you'd like to find out more
about mohammed bin salman
please click on the link below thank you
and don't forget to subscribe